the reason I think that shamanism is so
important is because I think what it
really boils down to is a revaluing of
personal identity and that when you
strip away the feathers and the chants
and all the anthropological gimm
crackery that goes along with it what
makes it so compelling and so attractive
is that it is a more authentic state of
being somehow now why seems to me that
the reason why is because theories about
the world are based on direct experience
the shaman is a kind of provisional
scientist making it up as he or she goes
along constantly willing to revise and
keep it open-ended and information
imported from without is extremely
suspicious which is the exact opposite
of the way science for example does its
work in science if you have a bizarre
result or a peculiar finding you
immediately say well go check the
literature see if anyone else ever got
this before then get them on the phone
and we'll see if we can't duplicate what
they were doing what this creates is
what we have which is a vast low-grade
inductively derived image of reality
where only those things which happen
with the greatest regularity and the
greatest predictability are
authenticated by our languages so we can
talk about rain and sunrise and meal
time
and obligation because these things are
repetitiously before us to the point
where they have become known as smooth
stones are known what is not
repetitiously before us is the edge of
cognition the unique part of our own
felt experience of reality and the
reason for this is very deeply rooted in
the culture it's that we believe in
these bizarre notions like consensus
like uniformity of phenomena
predictability probability I mean
everyone here believes in probability
who here could explain it to the
satisfaction of anyone I mean we are
adrift and embedded in a matrix of
unexamined linguistic excuses for
avoiding looking at how weird it is and
that is what the shaman is not the
shaman first of all it basically has no
real history cannot consult vast
libraries is not in touch with the
reputations the overwhelming stuffy
reputations of his antecedents hundreds
of years in the past the shaman can
usually ask one guy or one woman older
than himself and that elder represents
the in what for us would be an entire
epigenetic cosmos of data banks
libraries hieroglyphic records museum
drawers crammed with artifact Turia so
forth and so on
so the shamans intellectual horizon in
terms of what we call historicity is
very foreshortened consequently
everything has to be explained out of
energy that is unleashed in the psyche
energy of speculation of myth making of
imagination and this is in fact then
what the function becomes what the
shamans are doing they are not consuming
culture they are generating it and
herein lies the point for us we must
generate culture rather than consume it
to the degree that we take this ideal
upon ourselves what people say you know
is it enough to just clean up your diet
I mean how can we react in a in a
evermore stultifying political
environment and I'm very loathe to try
and deeply answer that because I don't
trust myself I don't know what I'm
talking about
but it does seem to me that the great
weapon is art because art is confusing
art hides a multitude of sins and can
serve many masters at once it is
subversive it is cheap to produce and if
we take seriously the notion that
society is an environment an ideological
jungle of competing memes then it's
reasonable to suppose that the most
articulate ly and clearly constructed
myths will in fact come to be but he he
who can tell the best story or she who
can tell the best story will see that
story come to be this is what the
shamans are doing for their societies
they are exemplars and this is a point
that I want to make very clearly because
I was published in the LA press as
knocking the venerable habit of using
quartz crystals so I want to talk for a
moment about the shaman as
prestidigitator the shaman as showbiz
and point out that really what what
shamans understand is that the world is
not as it appears and this is big news
everywhere no culture is entirely
comfortable with the news that it's
living in a fool's paradise but in the
in the tribal situation where sometimes
living groups number under a hundred and
people are living and let's say an
extreme environment like the Highland
savannas of Central Asia or the Amazon
jungle there is a social cohesiveness
that Brooks no illusions about what
people are I mean it's pretty funky but
out of it comes the exemplar the
exceptional individual what we call I
believe intellectuals and the
intellectual is alienated and seized
more deeply into things than everybody
else because everybody else is just
running around inside the cultural forum
and it's very easy to run around inside
the cultural forum and never to question
it regardless of what it is but the what
in Western society is institutionalized
as a vast edifice of edge work
personified originally in the idea of
the universities and then later in the
idea of the scientific and avant-garde
artistic community this this institution
that empowers the exploration of the
unknown in these tribal societies is
boiled down to just one dude or one
woman and that person's job is to push
the envelope to push the cultural
envelope and to come back and report on
strange things and to confound the
political leaders and and
to control the weather and ensure good
hunting and work miraculous cures and
make everyone feel good about themselves
and through the production of poetry
dance mask-making
chanting to give permission for cultural
evolution
to empower experiment to invite people
to journey into the cultural self-image
so so the the shamans are really in a
way micro vectors for movement into the
future
they are the anticipate
[Music]